cada día nuevos casos graves de malaria
son tratados en este hospital en la
región de kisumu el clima es húmedo y
caliente y los mosquitos son
devastadores esta mujer joven corre el
riesgo de sufrir un aborto a causa de
una crisis aguda de la enfermedad
tu bebé se alimenta gracias al cordón
umbilical como tienes malaria eso puede
afectar al niño porque destruye la
sangre en tu cuerpo
la malaria es la carga de este hospital
dentro de las 10 enfermedades más
frecuentes es la que causa más muertes
cada año la malaria mata a más de 10.000
personas en kenia el 27 por ciento de
los niños menores de 5 años la contraen
así que cuando se presentó la
oportunidad de poner a prueba una vacuna
el gobierno aprovechó la ocasión
esperando lograr reducir la mortalidad
en esta clínica muchos bebés la reciben
de manera gratuita
ya vacunaron por primera vez a los 6
meses ahora tienen 7 así que les pondré
su segunda dosis de la vacuna contra la
malaria
se encuentra bien con goyo si está bien
estaba
muy bien le pondré la segunda vacuna no
son necesarias cuatro dosis antes de que
el bebé cumpla dos años
pero
esta vacuna es muy buena es una solución
adicional a las medidas de prevención
que ya utilizamos como podemos
aún no hay datos científicos relativos a
la evolución en el número de casos desde
el comienzo de la campaña de vacunación
en 2019 pero según esta enfermera ya
hubo una mejoría en la situación
desde que empezamos la vacunación los
casos de malaria al mal eran
cada vez hay menos niños enfermos
en comparación con la época
si bien hasta el momento está en fase de
prueba su uso acaba de ser recomendado
por la organización mundial de la salud
este laboratorio recopila los datos de
la región y analiza las muestras
buscando el parásito responsable de la
enfermedad
tratamos de determinar hasta qué
proyecto se ha expandido la malaria en
la región y
comparamos los datos antes y después de
la vacunación y queremos conocer la
evolución de la transmisión de la
malaria
la vacuna permite reducir un 30% los
riesgos de casos graves después de
haberle administrado a 800.000 niños el
estudio también ha permitido determinar
que no tiene efectos secundarios graves
si los perfiles de seguridad son buenos
no ha habido problemas o sucesos
anormales que puedan indicar que esta
vacuna no es segura de boxing pero la
vacuna por sí sola no le pondrá fin a la
enfermedad en kenia otros investigadores
se tratan de aportar soluciones
complementarias
en el condado de queens ya gas también
hay mosquitos por todas partes la causa
son los campos de arroz y su sistema de
irrigación
estos científicos se vienen a tomar
muestras de los especímenes particulares
que están contaminados por un microbio
como el micro o libia es un simbionte
que se encuentra los mosquitos bloquea
la transmisión de la malaria entre los
mosquitos así que estamos buscando
especímenes que sean portadores para
utilizarlos como instrumentos de control
de la enfermedad
el micro es polilla fortalece el sistema
inmune del mosquito y le permite ser
resistente al parásito responsable de la
malaria
en su laboratorio los investigadores
estudian las maneras de transmitir el
microbio a gran escala
estas son todas las muestras no no hay
otra caja aquí
dos cajas cuando éstas son unos 606
anderson
los machos son disecados para estudiar
el contagio por su parte de las hembras
serán cuidadas con mucha atención
la dejaremos poner sus huevos y
determinaremos cuáles son portadores del
micrófono y nos separaremos o dejaremos
que nazcan y realizaremos experimentos
con ellos una madre contagia a toda su
progenitura y los machos contagian a las
hembras durante la reproducción así que
eso nos da dos posibilidades de
transición en las poblaciones que
aún serán necesarios varios años para
que el microbio pueda ser propagado a
gran escala según los investigadores con
el tiempo podría ser parte de la
solución para la epidemia combinado con
la vacuna yo creo que la clave para
resolver el problema de la malaria y los
ver en distintos momentos el ciclo de
transmisión es con estrategias
complementarias y esteros que estamos
trabajando en una nueva parte 17 y creo
que esta herramienta podría incluso ser
utilizadas mucho con las otras prisa
tenemos ahora se están llevando a cabo
múltiples estudios para frenar la
epidemia si bien aún no están a la orden
del día la vacuna y los descubrimientos
realizados en kenia permiten esperar una
solución eficaz para el problema en el
curso de las próximas décadas